okay our next speaker is Christopher
Bedford he serves as editor in chief of
the Daily Caller
news foundation he also serves on the
boards of young Americans for freedom
and the national journalism Center his
top-notch writing has appeared in a
number of publications including The
Wall Street Journal the New York Post
the Federalist and the American mind he
is a frequent guest on the Fox News
Channel Fox Business Network and the
Catholic News Service and he's also the
author of a book and I have to confess I
really do like the title the art of the
Donald lessons from America's
philosopher in chief lastly I would be
remiss if I did not mention that in
October last year he married a Hillsdale
College alumna the former Katharine
freights so congratulations he'll be
he'll be speaking today on the topic
Trump in the media would you please
welcome Christopher Bedford
thank you
and thank you to dr. Arnn Doug Jeffery
Matt Bell Samantha Strayer for bringing
me out here to this fantastic gathering
is not too common in California these
days I was lucky enough to marry a
Hillsdale graduate Katie she was a
cheerleader at Hillsdale she was a Kappa
Kappa Gamma at Hillsdale she studies
video games for a living now which is
what she hide she hated when I first met
her and she's absolutely into it but she
also when she was at Hillsdale she
studied finance and somehow despite that
being her focus came out of college with
more understanding of Austrian economics
and Plato and Aristotle than people who
went to my college who majored in those
things and it's not because she had a
specific interest it's because the
education was so darn good and also I
have Hillsdale to think forget building
the foundation making it a little bit
easier for me to bring her across the
Tiber back to Rome in the Catholic faith
and but she's not unique from a lot of
the people I've met in Washington DC who
went to Hillsdale I noticed as soon as I
got I've lived in DC for 15 years and
the swamp it feels like a hot tub now
and the people I've met over the years
from Hillsdale have always impressed me
absolutely blown me away
well-read well-rounded deep thinkers
seriously civic minded very interested
and Hillsdale of course receives no
federal funding and I think I've made it
a rule so discussing this with the wife
that if my kids want any Chris Bedford
funding they'll go to Hillsdale or
something like it
but they are they stand out so much in
Washington DC because DC is a city of
deeply deeply stupid people with there's
no grasp of history at all people can't
remember what it was like before
President Donald Trump they can't
remember what it was like before
President Barack Obama they can't
remember what it was like before net
neutrality regulations they think it's
the apocalypse and they're the worst
kind of stupid because they're very
arrogant and extremely smug and I would
like to preface this that the gentleman
i sat with today from the Orange County
Register our or not who I'm talking
about but every other member of the
media is Who I am talking about and my
reporters complain to me we have a lot
of young folks I'm one of the old people
in the office that's which we pay very
little and work them very hard and my
reporters complain about all their
colleagues on the hill who they cover
news with and people they meet at the
Capitol in the White House how how
shallow and self-absorbed and stupid
they are
and I unfortunately can't tell them that
it gets any better the higher you rise
in media those people come right with
you you look around and it's annoying to
see I mean you don't want to wish a LAN
anyone you won't ever want to succeed
but it's amazing how many terrible
people succeed in Washington DC just
compete continuously failing upward so
speaking of the media getting everything
wrong leading up to the campaign for
president I had heard I think as anyone
who was reading the news that President
Donald Trump was a cold fish a kind of
guy who could never do retail politics
he wasn't a handshake or he was an ivory
tower or not ivory tower but glass tower
Manhattan businessmen he had nothing in
common with the workers of America with
the people you'd have to meet in the
campaign trail this wasn't his style he
was a germaphobe all these different
things I'd also heard that Rubio was a
nice guy and that Jeb Bush was
unbeatable
and I started to notice that something
was amiss on the campaign trail actually
meeting with these folks the first time
I noticed something was very interesting
about President Donald Trump and I was
slower than a lot of a lot of maybe
people in this room was in Iowa when we
went out about an hour and a half
everything in I was at least an hour and
a half from anything else in Iowa and we
went out to a gymnasium to hear the
president's are the future presidents
speak and I noticed that the entire
crowd the the audience most of the men
had jeans and boots a Vietnam War shirt
leather jacket and a Vietnam War hat
this was very much a crowd that I was
told would have no interest in a guy who
walks in there and a custom Brioni suit
with a red trucker hat on and I noticed
that and never lie on the campaign trail
stops most of the most of the
presidential candidates they would give
the exact same speech but they would
change what they were wearing so they
would roll up their sleeves and take off
their cufflinks in a working-class area
they'd put on their suit in a
middle-class area and they what oddly
swap it out for a vest in a wealthy area
president Trump didn't do any of that he
never dressed up once and this group
folks who were going there with their
family their wives their children they
didn't mind at all he seemed to connect
with them and another myth he does run
out of energy he actually sat down for
this speech I've never seen it but the
campaign trail was exhausting and I was
talking to some of the makeup girls and
they're an interesting folks to talk to
you because they walk around go around
in the campaign trail and they see all
the people who are on TV the Talking
Heads the politicians and they see them
in a closed corridor where no one else
can see them no cameras are on there's
no fans there assist them so you kind of
get an idea just like the same way you
get an idea of somebody how they treat
the bartender or the waiter and they
told me that the meanest person on the
campaign trail and I haven't personally
experienced this was Marco Rubio he's
mr. nice guy right he's always been kind
of me and that the nicest person was
Donald Trump and that surprised me
Tucker took us out when around the
campaign trail to a steak house in New
Hampshire and we got there and I was
pretty excited about that because he was
paying and we're talking to the maitre d
saying any candidates come in to the
steak house and he said no way New
Hampshire is right now and a mess
there's massive drug problem there's a
problem with poverty there's a problem
with lack of education and anyone who's
a candidate for a president here doesn't
go to the nicest steak house in
Manchester if they go to the diners they
go to the burger stands they watching
candidates eat is like still one of the
grossest parts of the entire election
and then I saw Secret Service coming in
and I thought wow we got Hillary Clinton
she can't get away from it's he's such
an elitist we're gonna have a story out
of this and then the entire Trump family
walked in and there's no story there
Donald Trump eat steak everyone knows us
because he's himself he's not pretending
to be out there and he walked right up
to us because he recognized Tucker and
he just lit up the table he started
grabbing people by the shoulders shaking
hands taking pictures with children he
was just out of the debate and Trump I
really doubt that he was too concerned
about Rubio's health but he seems to be
that day he's like I'm looking at him
he's sweating he's sweaty are you okay
are you okay Annie and then he grabbed
one of our reporters by the shoulder and
he goes this guy works he works nights
he works weekends he never stops he
never stops and we all knew that this
guy was unreachable after jeopardy it
was we used to make fun of him there was
no shot but Trump made him feel like the
biggest guy in the room even though
everyone knew he was fibbing he made
everyone he lit up the room and the next
morning we went to a diner and this was
the day of the New Hampshire primary I
got in there early a little hungover as
reporters do and when I walked in Jeb
Bush was sitting alone at the counter
looking like a sad American painting
just not having a good day
down-on-his-luck
he gave a quick interview to Steve Doocy
and Tucker for Fox & Friends and he left
and then Chris Christie came in he came
into the back door and he's supposed to
be you know the man's man the brawler
he'll fight you on the boardwalk if you
make fun of him and he came in the back
door gave a quick interview and was gone
and then Secret Service came in and
President Trump came in with his family
or then businessman Trump came in with
Cory Lewandowski sitting there in the
corner on his cell phone his wife the
whole entourage and by the time he sat
down he knew everyone in the kitchen
staffs names he yells in the middle of
the camera he goes who are you voting
for Susie and she yells back America and
he says the terms of the camera goes of
course I knew she was gonna say that
otherwise he wouldn't a master and I got
the whole crowd going and then an hour
later I still had to go through Secret
Service use the restroom because he hung
out he got a big massive stack of
pancakes gigantic and sat there just
eating and talking with people like no
other candidate had done I thought the
press obviously does not understand this
man bag and they deeply hate him
completely hate him and the press likes
to pretend we like to pretend that we
liked the last president when they're
gone
nowadays you remember the Reagan funeral
I mean it was just lauding it was
everyone thought everyone was Reagan's
best friend he was the last president he
United us of course if you go just 70
miles north of here to the reagan ranch
for the reagan center in santa barbara
they have a great clip in the wall this
is plane over and over again the things
that the media said about Ronald Reagan
when he was president that he was senile
that he was stupid that he was evil that
he was portraying America's interests
that he was betraying America's
principles they like to defend that now
but reporters they don't remember
yesterday it's unbelievable they think
that right now is the worst time in
American history I like to remind them
of 1968 or maybe the 1860 is something
we've been discussing here I think the
country has been a little bit more
divided
they don't understand President Trump
they don't understand a lot of what's
going on here in Washington DC but the
funny part is Trump actually deeply
understands them he can get right to
them he can turn them on he can turn
them off you can pour water on their
circuits and here's a story and it gets
a little obscene because the president
gets a little obscene sometimes but it
was the week of McConnell's failure to
repeal Obamacare
Mitch Mitch McConnell had promised a
vote by June 30th before the
independence day break had been years
and years in the coming and many
campaign trail speeches on it and the
press was Ben Washington practically
salivating they were so excited for him
to fail they were they were asking
questions like oh why won't he just ask
the democratic party to help him is that
gonna be so hard and everyone and ever
anywhere knew full well that the
Democratic Party was not interested in
helping the GOP repeal Obamacare there
was not going to be a compromise on this
issue the guys authors a political
playbook which is a morning reading in
Axios in Washington DC were absolutely
electric for this failure but the
morning of the failure to repeal
Obamacare only three people definitely
knew that the Republicans didn't have
the votes now as John Cornyn the whip
Mitch McConnell president Donald Trump
probably vice president Mike Pence
everyone was waiting for it
and at 9:30 in the morning we get a
tweet this was back when just at the
beginning of him doing this fake news
CNN is looking at big management changes
now that they got caught falsely pushing
their phony Russian stories ratings way
down and then 17 minutes later so they
caught fake news CNN cold but what about
NBC CBS and ABC what about the failing
New York Times The Washington Post they
are all fake News and nine hours he went
silent the press went absolutely wild
how dare he attacked the press and now
they're a little bit more used to it so
he has to come up with new tricks but
it's not too hard to trick them it's
like coming up with new debt games for
the
cat here's here's a ball of tinfoil I
was at the tune in that day which is a
great watering hole if you're ever in
Washington DC covered in taxidermy $3
beers and the news switched for about
five minutes to cover a Mitch
McConnell's press conference saying that
they did not have the votes to repeal
Obamacare and then they switched right
back to the president making fun of CNN
how dare he I mean America's health care
system is important but nothing in the
mind of a DC journalist is more
important than the DC journalist they
are the heroes the well sung heroes and
two days later though they had another
chance all right they get their eye back
on the ball wait a second we're supposed
to be here to pound on the GOP Friday as
they leave for the for the break that'll
be the time to change the new subject so
President Trump had to do something a
little bit more than just make fun of
CBS and he did you might remember this
one I heard poorly rated
morning Joe speaks badly of me don't
watch anymore that how come low IQ crazy
Mika along with psycho Joe came and then
the dot-dot-dot and everyone in DC is
just waiting waiting for what's coming
next
it's the greatest feeling
tomorrow log our three nights in a row
around New Year's Eve and insisted on
joining me she was bleeding badly from a
facelift I said no that got their
attention you would be forgiven for
thinking that Trump had just sacrificed
a baby on the altar of Cthulhu instead
of insulting one of the most powerful
famous women in the world with access to
the corridors of power and a very
successful television show for cosmetic
surgery
they Joe and mica delayed their vacation
I know that because the MSNBC Chiron had
a countdown that said Joe and Myka
canceled vacation to address president's
comments in the morning
she she released an entire column
talking about how her mother had
suggested a quote chin tweak my mom says
some pretty mean things to me after I
get off from television - she thinks I
need Botox I'm not getting it yet so
holding out
but the Donald Trump show was on the air
for 24 hours a day he commanded what the
press was covering how they were
covering it he dominated the
conversation not granted it wasn't a
great conversation for the president he
was called uncouth he was called I mean
not since Jefferson versus Adams ever
seen such amazing insults hurled back
and forth at each other but they were
not talking about the failure of the
Republican Party they were talking about
President Donald Trump so I was having a
drink that Friday evening and one of the
Senate offices for the gentleman who was
in charge of communication on the
Obamacare front and he said we weren't
getting anything from Senate leadership
we had no idea about the lack of the
votes but the press didn't come they
didn't even care he was one of two
things either Donald Trump's a PR genius
or divine intervention and you can tell
me which one you decide and you know we
can figure that out later
over over dinner maybe so the press has
tried to grow wise to this they actually
asked occasionally for a moment when
we're talking about some scandal or some
trip they'll say well what aren't we
talking about right now because
typically when the president does
something that seems out of the blue
it's to change the conversation but they
think they don't have the attention they
don't have the focus on it they can't
help themselves he does things like the
classic tricks of the State of the Union
where you say something like we've freed
women from sexual slavery on the border
because you know that if the Democrats
refused to stand up for that thing then
they look really silly there was a
couple times during the speech when
congresswoman were whacking okgo Cortes
and saying stand up he said referring
people from sexual slavery this is okay
we can be proud of this
did you notice that the loudest applause
line that the women in white gave
themselves during the State of the Union
was for themselves it was pretty amazing
so help trick them he'll kill call ms-13
animals and then where's the press do
the press spends the next 48 hours
defending ms-13 it's it's unbelievable
how quickly he tricks them but it's
because because the press is thoroughly
thoroughly corrupt except for the Orange
County Register Lara Logan great war
correspondent said in a podcast last
week honestly she must be looking to get
fired the 85% of journalists are
registered Democrats all the coverage on
Trump all the time is negative and she
called that distortion and she's right
but the press aren't even normal
Democrats if you walk into the average
newsroom in New York or Washington DC it
might be a perfect representation of
America 30 percent black 20 percent 30
percent Hispanic a perfect racial mix
but if you say who here goes to church
on Sunday you're not gonna get a lot of
responses if you say who here voted for
President Donald Trump
forget about him president Romney or
senator Romney who voted for President
Bush maybe a few hands a smattering of
hands but largely despite looking
different despite you know 50% gay all
the different things that they hit it
was a cheap one
they don't have any cultural connection
to most Americans if you remember that
very brief blip of time when the press
was looking at themselves and saying
what did we do wrong after Trump was
elected even the Democrats were doing
that saying well we obviously missed a
huge voter bloc we obviously missed a
train they later switched it to Russia
and this Russia's fault in the Ku Klux
Klan for a minute they even plan two
tours of America I looked at it was
either buzz for you to the huffington
post at across America tour so they
could understand what people outside of
New York thought but the cities they
went to you were like Columbus Ohio
Austin Texas oh these are great cities I
was just in Columbus and I love Austin
but they're not the heartland you don't
get a great idea of what the average
Ohio voter or Texan voter feels like
from going to a hipster bar in a college
town but they didn't even know that they
were very proud of themselves so the
press has a role to play an important
role that remind you of that all the
time there they're at they're positively
Knights of a free republic but more and
more the American media is not simply
not asking the questions which is what
we're supposed to do they're deciding
what questions can be asked they are
making themselves arbiters of what is
polite conversation what is an
acceptable line of questioning what is
deemed racist what is deemed
irresponsible what is deemed an assault
on the Constitution remember this all
began pretty early when a
president-elect Trump's sneaked away to
a steak house in New York City they
called that an assault on the First
Amendment because they couldn't cover
him look at what they did to the
Covington kids those high schoolers now
so we have elite journalists in New York
City people on with media platforms
making million dollars a year access to
power great education talking about
Catholic school kids from a town in
Kentucky who they say are privileged
and they're sneering they said look what
they did with this smollett case in
Chicago the idea that at 2:00 a.m. in
one of the coldest nights in Chicago
people wearing red Magga hats were
wandering around with the noose and
bleach saying this is maggot country
will they kick people where they
recognized from a show called Empire is
so unbelievable it doesn't pass the
sniff test and it's funny as Smollett
wanted to be a script writer and I think
he should find a new career because
that's a terrible plot line but if you
looked even during the election there
was an article that got repeated and
repeated and repeated that in Northern
Virginia which is a very wealthy
government subsidized area of Virginia a
lot of traffic that the Ku Klux Klan was
handing out joints to deter the black
vote that's that's not happening that's
deeply stupid if somebody wants weed
they'll get their own weed and no one's
gonna walk up to a voting booth and say
oh the Klan just gave me a joint I guess
I'll go home these kind of stories that
are completely unbelievable the idea
that a billion dollar or a lecture
election was swayed by 1 million dollars
in spending or less by Russia they must
have the best campaign consultants in
the entire planet the over and over
again these completely farcical
unbelievable narratives pushed and the
reason why they're believed or because
people in the press have no outside view
they've never been challenged in college
they haven't they haven't been
challenged by their peers they're
surrounded by people who think very much
like them and they haven't even
considered that they could be wrong or
that if they repeat something to
themselves and maybe it's it's
completely false and they're all
convinced of the absolute wickedness of
our president and he's able to twist
them like I said have you seen how him
telling NATO to give more money to
contribute to NATO's defense is playing
into the hands of Putin
that was an interesting one out magazine
which is a gay magazine recently called
his move to decriminalize homosexuality
around the world American cultural
imperialism that was very interesting
and it's hard to keep track of all these
different things how do they unite
because they're not even traditionally
liberal talking points they've been
changing dramatically with time it's
mostly just hash tag resist opposition
to trump but the one thing that connects
all of these things is that they guard
the elite they guard the vested
interests of the United States they the
press is more than ever exposed itself
as a praetorian guard for Silicon Valley
they'll attack every now and then for
for the Democratic establishment for the
liberal colleges these are the things
that cannot ever be touched in anyone
especially President Trump who tries to
will be attacked by them they're here to
protect the wealthy from from the people
and it's an unbelievable place to find a
free press in but it connects them and
basically everything they do we at the
News Foundation are trying to counter
that we have a non-profit news
organization where we train journalists
over two years
in the classics not nearly as deeply as
a Hillsdale education some of our best
reporters are from Hillsdale but we read
basic economics read about the founding
of the country and also read about how
for example calling your sources
confirming a story before it goes live
how one anonymous source does not make a
story how the dishonesty of the press
how if you've got three people who are
former officials and one person who's a
current official the new york times
they'll mask that as according to a
number of current and former officials
that means they've got one current
official and there's other people they
may be former they have no idea what's
going on in that room anymore we teach
our reporters that that's bad and then
we try to get them jobs at liberal it's
because the center-right is phenomena
good at opinion I've dominated
talk-radio dominated the magazines as
when they existed there starting
unfortunately to leave us dominated the
blogosphere dominated cable but they
haven't dominated the news the New York
Times Washington Post still have
thousands of reporters who are working
all the time did you see that the
Washington Post launched an
investigative unit when President Trump
was elected they'd gotten rid of it
under President Obama how unbelievable
is that now they need to investigate
Russia Russia Russia all the time so
we've sent reporters to CBS CNN Newsweek
the hill and some of them get co-opted
nice to have their phone number so I
call them and I tell them I think so the
civil society that we have is worth
defending the press is an institution
worth defending but it needs to be held
to account the arguments that you used
to have maybe around the Thanksgiving
table about whether the press is is
liberal that people don't even have that
argument anymore because it's even your
family members some might disagree with
you have disagreed if you now agree with
you they just have to decide whether or
not they think it's good that the press
is part of the resistance but the First
Amendment is one of the greatest gifts
that we have one of the greatest rights
that we have and it all it takes is
responsible responsible journalism well
trained to try and fix it it's sad to
see what's happening to the press with
the bankruptcies people going out of
business but I've at the same time I've
never seen a group of people who deserve
it more than they do it's hard because
it's my living but it's totally deserved
it's it's practically a suicide at some
points so we're working to take it back
with some of the Hillsdale graduated
folks that we've hired over the years
pulling my wife or worked for me for a
time live the American dream go to DC
marry your boss
it was tough going to work with her
everyday we're working to take that back
and provide an example for young folks
who are dedicated to well by their beer
because they won't be able to afford it
everyone's parents were always upset
with them and they come a journalist but
it is the most fun and it is an
important job and hopefully when all
this is over we'll still have a free
press I think we will and one that can
stand strong with our Republic for the
next 250 years thank you
I can't threaten your dessert like dr.
Arne did but I'd be happy to answer any
questions right behind you sir okay
thank you very much for that
presentation clear hi thinking is always
indispensable I'd like to ask you a
fundamental question namely what is
essentially the problem of the press and
by way of suggesting an answer but
Thomas Jefferson once was written to by
a fella Wanda started a newspaper and
Jefferson was in the White House at the
time and he was asked what are the
ingredients of a good newspaper which
could be said about the media as a whole
and in that reply in which he said many
things he said this is particularly
important true facts and sound
principles and so much of conservative
thought is because is focused on the
true facts which is understandable
because so many of them are not reported
or suppressed but those sound principles
as you indicated your last few remarks
are indispensable in other words the the
media need to be factual they need to be
accurate they need to be fair but they
also need to be committed to the
American Republic and the principles
that underlay the fact of the whole
foundations of the system because
without that they're without any kind of
guidance what is your opinion on that
thank you
Charles Marie talked about special
classes of people in America and there's
a very interesting book coming apart and
the press was one a specific example he
gave of not people who are not super
well educated extremely wealthy or
extremely powerful who hang out with
people who are all the time and it's
that's a rare thing in most societies to
have a lower middle class to middle
class group of people who have access to
the lunch tables the dinner tables the
bar rooms and salons of the ruling elite
of the country the press has that for
sure it causes a lot of envy
Porter's love free lunches and open bars
the because of that I think a lot of our
press have started to consider
themselves in the similar fashion to
what our elite do which is as global
citizens as people who don't that the
Pledge of Allegiance would be tacky
to say a prayer before dinner would be
imperialism to think of this country as
one given to us the fought for by
American patriots
to them it's more of a thing about slave
owners in the past about the darkness of
American history the Howard Zinn guide
to history and there's not a strong
allegiance amongst lots of the large
part of the press to the actual
well-being of the United States I mean
if you've read in the last few just in
the last week the press has had a sob
story about the false asylum seekers who
are no longer seeking asylum because
President Trump it seems too hard for
them now they're fighting very very hard
for the citizens of Honduras and
Guatemala much harder than they are for
the average worker in America and I were
people who they you think they would
have more to do with I don't know if you
caught the sob stories of government
workers who didn't get a paycheck for
three weeks but those networks won't
even let angel moms on they have no
sympathy at all for the Americans who've
lost children brothers sisters parents
to crimes committed by illegal
immigrants they consider themselves
citizens of the world and America has a
bad actor who they're here to police and
without that without understanding the
foundations of a free society how we got
here they're just like spoiled children
in the Playhouse breaking things
criticizing things and attacking things
and that's one of the reasons why after
in our second we call them semesters but
really they're just pizza dinners with
speakers and beer
I gotta incentivize our guys to come in
after we do the basics of reporting we
focus on the foundations of a free
society at the Daily Caller News
Foundation so we can push how we got
here what made this country free what
made this country great men
like Churchill who in it saved Western
civilization and why Western
civilization is actually something worth
saving which a lot of folks don't
believe it's amazing also but by and
large a lot of them are just stupid and
lazy
we are the laziest class of people it's
unbelievable not me of course or the ERC
register
yes sir
and very little prescriptive so I'd like
to hear perhaps some of your
prescriptions on how to cure it now with
all the wealth that we have as
Republicans you look at Forbes 400 list
why haven't they taken over bought out
CNN
why haven't they endowed decent
journalism school not Columbia where I
went but that's impossible
and taking an aggressive approach a
direct attack as a prescription rather
than always complaining about how they
are there's nothing to cure it within
the description
you have to have a direct attack
unfortunately you're in a room that
breaks that mold the folks who are here
supporting the work the Hillsdale does a
lot of the GOP donors class as well won
the GOP donor classes largely
disconnected from the GOP base and
that's been a problem for a while that's
why you had a donor class that seriously
thought that Jeb Bush was going to win
the presidential nomination and were so
surprised to see that change and that
realignment is going on currently it
sounds painful it's not easy to have a
spine that's like this try to get split
back to that but by and large
conservatives have neglected the fight
on college campuses and have ceded the
ground to liberals the gentleman I was
sitting next to at lunch today was
talking about endowing a chair at one of
his colleges that he supports for free
enterprise and was told the free
enterprise was a pejorative he decided
to stop giving money to that College as
I understand however most people don't
Bill Buckley wrote about this right
after he got out of Yale got a man at
Yale he said the people who fund our
universities have the power to stop this
a lot of them are conservative all of
them are successful in business a lot of
them a lot of people who are
conservative generally are successful in
business but they don't they don't hold
the universities to account like they
should and groups like Hillsdale and
organizations like the Daily Caller News
foundation that and there are a couple
other colleges out there as well don't
worry I want to advertise them dr. Arnn
who were producing who are who are
teaching the classics who are pushing
back against this and who are creating a
group that can hopefully change the
trajectory that's what we're doing at
the News Foundation there's very few
other places that are doing original
news reporting on the center right but
as a Catholic conservative I think we're
all doomed and that's okay so I'm not
necessarily the optimist to go to go
with on this but I am seen I have seen
some good moves on the right the
difficulty with places like CNN is the
culture is so strong there and if you if
your colleagues think you are bigoted or
they think that you're a quote on the
wrong side of the history which is one
of the creepiest accusations you can
launch it somebody won it says that
you're on the right side of history and
it immediately calls in mind Nazism or
Ku Klux Klan ISM or some other ISM if
your colleagues are doing that it makes
a lot of good people be quiet for their
jobs and even conservative outlets like
Fox News they still recruit from a
talent pool in New York City and
Washington DC they still even then with
more conservative leaning organizations
you have to battle that it's a
hard-fought battle there's no easy
solutions but a group like this sitting
here focusing on education and what's
amazing is a group like this a lot of
the people here don't even actually
haven't even sent children through
Hillsdale they just know it's doing an
important job that's one of the most
positive things I've ever seen for I
think changing the youth and change in
the future
hi thanks for your pithy comments I'm
from Orange County unfortunately we
don't even have a Republican congressman
anymore which is hard to believe but I'm
curious three news stories that hit
light within the last week or two what
you and your peers actually really say
about number one the standing ovation
applause in the New York legislature
when post term abortion was approved and
number two the ridiculous idea of
building a train from the East Coast to
Europe and then most importantly giving
people a job a high paying job for
people that are unable but more
importantly unwilling to work and if
that I'm just blown away that that know
that those are even they even made the
news that that and what what does your
what does your peer group say when
things like that pop up in the news some
of my friends have just been thoroughly
broken by this whole thing I had a
friend who was reporter for CNN who
Trump scrambled his brain and now he
travels the world and a van he outfitted
with his wife camping and posted on
Instagram he was smart a lot of other
people whose brains are fried by
President Trump didn't leave and his
brain wasn't Friday just decided he was
done with it this Virginia stuff has
been very interesting now we have
somebody who a doctor a pediatrician who
said that children should be made
comfortable and allowed to die on a
table after they're born after
discussion with the family and he's
taken down for wearing blackface in
college that's a pretty twisted line of
what we deem an offense worthy of
impeachment and what we deem just
politics is normal then the entire group
it looks like is going down either for
accusations of sexual assault or
blackface and what's interesting is
I've never seen karma hit a group so
quickly as the Democratic Democrats of
Virginia when hashtag me to became a
thing and there was no longer a jury or
a trial when they tried to destroy judge
Cavanaugh based on accusations of sexual
assault
thank goodness meet you didn't exist
during to kill a mockingbird the and
they also accused Ralph Northam of being
or not Ralph Northam they accused the
Republican governor editorial candidate
of being a racist and now it comes out
that they've got awkward pictures in
their past and the press largely has
ignored the biggest scandal of all of
this which is letting children died on
the table
I mean actively illegal thing and
immoral do you know and Washington DC
during the government shutdown because
DC funds a lot of city services in
Washington you couldn't get a marriage
license but you could get a divorce that
was deemed essential I guess some folks
might agree with that at certain times
in their relationships but I thought
that was a sad comment on where we were
green dude the green new deal that was
something that gets me really excited
I'm looking forward to this I'm looking
forward to spring and I'm looking
forward to Democratic primaries Kamala
Harris and Cory Booker endorsing it and
a representative or casual critic as his
office having to withdraw her frequently
asked questions and say that the plan
was accidentally released after they
claimed it was doctored well Congress
from and you already had two
presidential candidates at least
endorsed it and it turns out who was a
mistake
we found a phenomenon with congressman a
casual Cortes and I assume the press has
found this as well outside of just my
office that Sheehan clicks she increases
the clicks on an article by about three
fold people are interested in her she's
photogenic she says any things she is
basically leading the Democratic Party
in certain levels and if you're a
Republican I should probably make you
happy
because I don't think she's leaving them
in a way that's very well thought out
she's a classic example of of what
college is outside of Hillsdale produce
and people it's like she's never been
cross-examined she's never had to
rethink any of her ideas he's never been
seriously challenged on this she
compared global warming to world war two
and said we'd all be dead in 12 years
she will not be held accountable for
that by the way will not in 12 years
time no one will hold her accountable
for that and I think that Winston
Churchill would disagree with her on the
severity of the issue of a cow
flatulence versus Hitler's Germany the
press has been careful with her though
it's easy old tack so last out she'll
say you're sexist for attacking her but
she's largely doing herself a discredit
well becoming very effective popular and
I look forward to covering her and I
think most of my colleagues look forward
to covering her over the years to come
should be interesting thank you I really
enjoyed your talk and on that AOC
question a quick thought before my
question so I like it her to that last
scene in Feldon Louie's driving off the
cliff I hope it comes true because I do
think they're following her as they head
for the cliff but my question is really
more about a missing ingredient perhaps
in your talk and maybe you said it I
missed it but there it seems to be an
enormous assumption by the media in
Washington and New York of about the
stupidity of the American public that we
accept this and I and I call back to my
Great Awakening as an army vet
Benghazi the fact that this the people
killed on that roof that night were
number two and three mortar shells
launched onto the roof and yet we
watched the president and the Secretary
of State try to just brush it off as an
unorganized guys people maybe going to
the movies trying to break in and carry
out an exercise and there's thousands of
vets that know that that attack took at
least five people with radio
communications and spotters to pull off
and pre-practice positioning and yet the
country is filled with people that
understand
what we were told by their two hybrid
leaders was an absolutely lie and the
press went along with it never did
anybody question how could that possibly
be true we have the facts in front of us
and yet we were supposed to as a nation
accept this absurd explanation from the
president and the media not one person
the media ever tried to call him on the
audience is actually far more trained
and critical than the media seemed to be
the that was one of the specific
examples I'm Irish so I hold grudges
forever and I haven't read The Economist
once since their initial Benghazi
coverage and I know that everyone seems
to like them because I've got a British
accent and that's it's nice we don't
have a ruling class accent of our own so
we like that accent the they said that
there was a number of former special
operations forces who were just hanging
out in Benghazi this this nice town you
know it's a nice place to visit who were
killed by an al-qaeda affiliate and that
never went in the basket er was there
there's nothing to see here
why ever would former special operations
forces be hanging out outside of Libya
outside of outside of the capital in
Benghazi in a place where they could be
attacked by mortars where they could be
raided where roads could be blocked off
they they didn't even seem to simply ask
that they take the government's line
over and over again the FBI said they
didn't do it they didn't do it there's
no more questions here it's amazing we
had a story of the day where the
Inspector General was upset that Hillary
Clinton's server had likely been hacked
at some point by a foreign government
the FBI refused to investigate we
reported that the FBI released a
statement that said we didn't find
anything in an investigation and the
press took that as an answer and said
that we were wrong it was a double
answer there was a non-answer the whole
story was that you didn't investigate
the Federal Bureau of Investigations we
know you didn't find anything in that
investigation but the press went along
because they're deeply stupid but a lot
of Washington DC screwed up the Benghazi
story in my opinion I was discussing
this with some of our editors
covered it for business insider and the
Marine Corps times are with us now
even the GOP messed up they made it so
much about this video on this lie that
the president told and the Secretary of
State told that our consulate was
attacked and our ambassador was killed
because somebody from Egypt living in
America had made fun of Mohammed it's
just another one of those very difficult
to believe stories but President Obama
was busy running guns to unvetted rebels
in Syria that's what they were doing out
there that's what the ambassador was
there for us what he was meeting with
the Turks for Fox News actually tracked
them down to the the freighter where
they said they were bringing them to
gather them together to destroy them
they were giving weapons that could take
down a passenger airliner to unvetted
terrorist affiliates to fight Assad
that's the real insanity of Benghazi and
no one was able to get to the bottom of
it they were called conspiracy theorists
by the victorian guard and the press the
democrats said it was racist to question
President Barack Obama and the
Republicans got hung up on the easy fish
of what the president clearly lied about
this video we know it wasn't the video
everyone missed the real story and also
a lot of people missed how our NATO ally
and I try to get to this but I couldn't
get I couldn't get more than one source
and I'm like the New York Times I wasn't
gonna claim me was more than one source
that the Turkish ambassador had left the
consulate at a time when locals had
reported that the al Qaeda affiliate had
already set up roadblocks that were
marked with Al Qaeda's signage flag
which means the Turks drove through
leaving an American consulate on Al
qaeda-affiliated blockade and didn't
call back there's not a single record
that they came and they warned the
Americans that they were surrounded by
al Qaeda
sounds like we were betrayed by a NATO
ally but I guess the president Trump
ever tried to get to the bottom of that
he'd be helping Putin
and they do think the American people
are stupid it is unbelievable and worse
than that they think that they're very
smart
they're very self-satisfied can you tell
I don't like reporters except for the
u.s. you register Chris one of my
favorite lines in all-time favorite
lines and is in movies is Colonel jessep
saying you can't handle the truth
I wonder what those of us in this room
those of us who are conservative and
still read or listen to the media what
we can do to hold George will and Bill
Kristol and people like them accountable
my wife and I have not watched national
television for over a year I turned it
on when I came to this conference and I
could only stand it for five minutes
even even Fox as has moved left and I
look at things like one American news
and other outlets and say what what are
we going to do to convince the Wills and
crystals of this world to to handle the
truth I don't think you will I think
Bill Kristol is a thoroughly broken man
he's somebody who had so much promise
and everyone assumed was gonna be good
and interest and he put together a
magazine that was good and interesting
for a period of time and then he took to
Twitter and it's rotten it's rotted his
brain he's ended he was Tucker Carlson
one of my good friends and my bosses
first bosses in Washington DC Tucker
looked up to him
cared what he thought disagreed with him
on a lot of different things but
considered him a friend and Bill Kristol
called him an anti-semite in a tweet he
didn't even call him didn't even text
him
didn't say hey buddy let's talk I think
your shows going down the wrong path
he's now living in some kind of strange
Fantasyland
remember when he recruited a Republican
whose name I can't even remember to run
against President Trump as a third party
candidate and then he spent that weekend
going to a carnival with his
grandchildren which I know cuz he
tweeted it that's not how you run an
opposition campaign to win president of
the United States that takes a lot of
work but he's more interested in a lot
of his friends are very interested in
simply attacking on television and going
on to the next dinner party how about
the fact that he's a frequent guest on
networks that think he is a war criminal
the people who were applauding him right
now cuz he says the right things about
the president are people who said that
he's responsible for millions of dead in
Iraq and thousands of dead Americans
because of his foreign policy blunders
but he says the right things about the
president he helps guard the elite so
now he's being welcomed in the best
thing you can do with George will and
Bill Kristol is to turn them off I get
to write mean things about them every
now and then but I don't have any
guarantee they read it maybe I can mail
it to them I did have a one this is a
really difficult moral ethical quandary
whether or not I should make fun of
David Brooks in a column because he
lives near me and he's got a pool and
there very few pools in Capitol Hill and
it gets very hot on Capitol Hill but I
decided that it was probably likely he
wouldn't see it so I wrote it anyways
those are the ethical challenges right
these these groups of the week the
standard they've made it the business
model to run themselves at a business
and there were some good people over
there Matt Leigh bash was phenomenal
Andy Ferguson was phenomenal but I do
admit that as an organization at the
News Foundation and before that the
for-profit Daily Caller
we had a deeply important mantra to
never operate in the red after the first
18 months of existence always operate in
the black always at least if you're not
making a lot of money don't be losing
money and I have a little bit of scorn
for members of the media Washington Post
the Weekly Standard rest in peace who
never had to pay attention to that who
just took dad's credit card and went
running with it until dad got bored and
cut it off the I think the media SH
that's an example of irresponsibility
using your platform to simply attack
your readership to attack people who
support Trump to call them the what did
what did Hillary Clinton call the
deplorable z' she's a nasty nasty woman
as President Trump once said that was an
interesting debate too he had the fervor
of an evangelist someone who I feel like
likeliness the president Trump has had
some kind of nearness to abortion in his
life is very high but I feel like like a
lot of people in the media he'd never
even considered it never thought deeply
about it until he ran for president
United States and he came out in Las
Vegas it's like someone had just told
him what abortion was and it blew him
what you could tell when he attacks
Hillary Clinton when Hillary Clinton
said it's Rho V Rho V Wade is a woman's
right you're attacking a woman's right
most Republicans would say well it's
settled law of the land my Christian
beliefs that lead me to think otherwise
and he went out eyes wide and said you
know what they do they take the baby and
they kill she's a nasty nasty woman like
someone had just told him do you what
abortion is I'd never seen such a
forceful defense of life ever on the
national stage and it came from
Manhattanite Donald Trump it's been very
interesting and he personally attacked I
think it was Senator Chris Coons maybe
messing that up a northeast senator a
Democrat for the party's switch on
abortion in a place where there were no
cameras it got leaks to the press they
confronted him at a dinner and said how
could you do this how could you possibly
do this so it's an interesting champion
we have there we have time for one more
question
is it effective calling fake news think
news I love it and I shouldn't admit
that the my favorite thing about the
fake news thing that Donald Trump is
used in weaponized right now if you hear
President Trump call something fake news
they say that's an assault on the First
Amendment and undermines democracy it
undermines America the first time you
might have heard the term fake news was
actually from the media when they're
attacking conservative news after
Hillary Clinton lost there was a serious
push to cut off conservative media's
legs they called it fake news who said
it was Russia funded there was a really
strange and surreal press conference
under the Obama White House were over
and over again the press secretary had
to remind the press that because of the
First Amendment they couldn't crack down
on media outlets at the White House
disagreed with the press was begging
them to it was unbelievable and they
were asking they were requesting the
help of Silicon Valley our overlords at
Facebook and Twitter to decide what was
fake and what was real and it may start
with something that's on its face false
one New York reporter pointed out to me
as an article that made a difference in
fake news that the Pope endorses Donald
Trump was gonna swing votes and I had to
point out to him that anyone who listens
to the Pope wasn't voting for a third
term abortionists so it was very
unlikely that switched a lot of votes
but the fake news thing came from the
media and it was deeply insidious trying
to get places shut down you know the
just access to the halls of Congress is
controlled by a committee of reporters
who vote on this al Jazeera has been
elected to this committee in the past an
outlet for a slave state unbelievable
turn and they have worked hard to deny
places that are center-right access to
Congress and I call that an assault on
media they've asked for censorship from
Silicon Valley they've asked for
censorship from government and while it
may start with a fake news story like
Pope endorses Donald Trump by tomorrow
it's gonna be anyone who's skeptical of
global warming being caused by man or
anyone who says that there was evidence
of voter fraud in Philadelphia how dare
we or anyone who questions the video
narrative and a bunch of contractors
hanging out in Benghazi narrative that
would be called fake news and shut down
so for President Trump to turn it around
and weaponize it it's one of the most
deeply just things I absolutely love it
and you know if you ever in Washington
DC when you go to the Smithsonian and
you see the portrait of souls burger oh
yeah owner of the New York Times the one
who turned it around years ago it the
description says he took over the
failing New York Times because at the
time it was failing and it's one of the
best exhibits in the Smithsonian Donald
Trump lives forever in there
thanks everyone this has been wonderful
you